-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Guys, it seems like there's
so much going on right now.
Father's Day is this Sunday.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Congress just held another
hearing about January 6th.
The first photo
of Ryan Gosling as Ken...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...in the "Barbie" movie is out.
And I just heard Jack Daniels
is teaming up with Coca-Cola
to sell a canned Jack & Coke.
[ Cheering and applause ]
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
Here we go.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
First up, this Sunday
is Father's Day.
It is the time to thank your dad
for everything
he's done for you.
It's a fun day to celebrate,
but you know what's not so fun?
The congressional hearings.
[ Laughter ]
They're investigating
January 6th.
That's when a mob went
after Mike Pence,
who, by the way, has as much
going on below the belt as
A Ken doll.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What can you do, you know?
He's a Ken doll.
I mean,
and Ken and Barbie,
they're a great couple.
I mean, they go together like
Jack & Coke.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, you can get it
as a premixed cocktail,
which is good news
if you still need a gift for
Father's Day.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Your dad deserves
something special.
Because it's not easy
raising kids.
I mean, before he had you,
your dad probably looked like
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ryan Gosling. I mean,
just look at him.
If that Ken walked
into a bachelorette party,
there'd be a full-on
Riot.
[ Laughter ]
People stormed the Capitol,
and took selfies
while they did it.
You know, they must've pregamed
with a few
canned cocktails.
[ Laughter ]
If you drink one, you drink six.
I mean, they go down
real smooth.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of down and smooth...
Poor Ken.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He'll never be able to be a
Dad. So...
[ Laughter ]
...in conclusion --
Nice abs.
Tastes bad.
Make it stop.
[ Laughter ]
Love you, Pop.
[ Cheering and applause ]
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
Thank you very much.
As I mentioned,
this Sunday is Father's Day.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Four?
-Four people, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's great.
Yeah, it's the day we thank Dad
for all the times
we went to him with a problem
and he said --
[ Changes accent ]
"Ask your mother."
[ Laughter and applause ]
On Father's Day,
you don't even have
to make breakfast in bed
because there's always
a half a baloney sandwich
on his nightstand.
[ Laughter ]
Let's be honest --
no one cares about Father's Day.
[ Laughter ]
Even the Hallmark Channel
does nothing for Father's Day.
[ Awws and laughter ]
Seriously, they'll air
an Arbor Day marathon
before a Father's Day movie.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Father's Day is
a lot different
than Mother's Day.
On Mother's Day,
every card looks like a novel.
On Father's Day, you basically
get the CliffsNotes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile, leading up
to Father's Day,
Kingsford released a new ad
for their charcoal.
It might just be me,
but it seems a little strange.
Watch this --
-This...
...gather around the grill
with...
because a Kingsford flame is the
perfect thing to stare at to...
[ Laughter ]
Squirt the lighter fluid.
Listen to him say...
...and realize it's
as close to...
as he's ever going to get.
[ Laughter ]
Stand there as he retells
the story of how...
[ Laughter ]
Finally work up
the courage to...
[ Laughter ]
Then listen to him reply...
[ Laughter and whistling ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That's right. Beautiful.
Well, this is fun --
the Westminster Dog Show
kicks off tomorrow
right here in New York.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Breeds are categorized
into groups,
including working,
sporting, and non-sporting.
It's the same way
dads classify their sons.
[ Laughter ]
[ Changes accent ]
I got one working,
one non-sporting.
[ Laughter ]
One not working.
Get this --
I read that President Biden
will soon release his plan
for the next pandemic.
Americans were like, "Awesome.
Wait, what next pandemic?"
[ Laughter ]
It's not much.
All they're planning to do is
mail everyone
a sour dough starter kit.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm kidding.
It's a highly detailed plan
called "Tiger King" Season 3.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, gas prices
are still soaring
and experts say that there's
no relief in sight.
With that in mind, we went
to our sound engineer,
Steve Mandel,
who's going to tell us
what he thinks about gas prices,
in a new segment called
"Steve Mandel's Rant Zone."
[ Laughter ]
-This is...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...the only place where you're
going to get...
If you can't handle the heat,
[ Laughter ]
stay away from the flames
because Steve Mandel...
...and...
And now, it's time to find out
what goes on
in the mind of this man.
-[ Sedately ]
I think gas prices are
too high.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been...
Consider yourself ranted.
-[ Sedately ]
Don't forget to smash
that like button.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Some entertainment news --
[ Laughter ]
I heard that a new Marvel
series, called "Wonder Man,"
is in the works at Disney+.
Finally, a superhero
for boys to relate to.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Wonder Man has superhuman
strength, speed, stamina,
and the ability to fight
copyright infringement lawsuits
from "Superman."
[ Laughter ]
Actually, Wonder Man's
super power is
hearing what Wonder Woman said
in the meeting
and then repeating it louder.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Booing ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hey, guys, I saw that
this Saturday is
Paul McCartney's 80th birthday.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I want to be real
for a moment.
His music means so much to me,
so, to honor him,
here's a special performance
of his most beautiful song,
"Let It Be."
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
[ Nervous laugh ]
Whew!
I know the rights to this
are super expensive, but, uh --
[ Laughter ]
I hope we cleared them.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Stage muted ]
-♪ Old MacDonald had a farm ♪
♪ E-I-E-I-O ♪
♪ And on his farm,
he had some pigs ♪
♪ E-I-E-I-O ♪
♪ With an oink-oink here
and an oink-oink there ♪
♪ Here an oink, there an oink,
everywhere an oink-oink ♪
♪ Old MacDonald had a farm ♪
♪ E-I-E-I-O ♪
-Thank you very much.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Thank you for the music,
Sir Paul.
[ Whistling ]
Hey, guys, I saw that LEGO's
is spending more than $1 billion
to build its first factory
in the U.S.
-Whoo!
-Yep, it will probably
take a while to build
because, halfway through,
they realize,
one brick's missing
and have to start over.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, you guys,
summer is officially here
and I read that today
is National Flip-Flop Day.
That's pretty fun.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-No, wait, wait.
-I love flip flops.
-Like, okay,
you love flip-flops.
What else?
-I mean, I mean, I like --
I like flip-flops.
I like tank tops.
-That's cool.
What else?
[ Laughter ]
-I like pawn shops
and bus stops.
I like listening to hip hop,
K-Pop, and doo-wop
nonstop at a coffee shop
on my laptop.
I like eating lamb chops
with Carrot Top and Fetty Wap,
drinking peach schnapps,
watching "RoboCop"
at a rooftop of a co-op.
[ Laughter ]
♪ I like rock steady, not bebop,
brooms, not mops ♪
♪ Sucking gumdrops
and lollipops with bellhops ♪
♪ Jamming is easy,
topping the sounds ♪
♪ Of Alka-Seltzer going
plop, plop ♪
-♪ Fizz, fizz ♪
♪ Oh, what a relief it ♪
-♪ Is...it nice to be naughty? ♪
♪ Is it naughty to be nice? ♪
-♪ Okay, okay, okay ♪
-♪ Is it naughty to be nice? ♪
♪ Naughty to be ♪
-♪ Okay ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
Listen to this -- a motorcyclist
in Minnesota was arrested
for going 144 miles per hour
and he said
that he was going that fast
to cool off from the heat.
[ Laughter ]
It actually worked
because he got to ride
in an air-conditioned
police car.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, like I said,
this Sunday is Father's Day
and there are so many
amazing dads out there
who do such great things
and the one thing we all know
dads can do
is dance.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
So, we went down to the streets
and asked dads to show us
their best moves
to celebrate Father's Day.
Here's some great dad dancing.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-♪ My money don't
jiggle, jiggle, it folds ♪
♪ I'd like to see you
wiggle, wiggle, for sure ♪
♪ It makes me wanna
dribble, dribble, you know ♪
♪ Riding in my Fiat,
you really have to see it ♪
♪ Six feet two in a compact,
no slack ♪
♪ Luckily the seats go back,
I've got a knack ♪
♪ To relax in my mind,
sipping some ♪
[ Electronic voice ]
♪ Red, red wine ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Happy Father's Day!